polina how are you i'm good sorry i'm
looking at beach towels on amazon prime
day
but looks like some of them like the
nice towels aren't on the prime what's
going on with the euro okay
for the
for the first time in 20 years the
exchange rate between the euro and the
us dollar has reached parity meaning
that the two currencies are worth the
same the euro hit one dollar on tuesday
down about 12 percent since the start of
the year yeah the euro is always like
more valuable than the
d yeah i can't speak today the euro is
more valuable than the dollar the dollar
has been strengthening
somebody like a brent johnson who has
been talking about the dollar milkshake
theory he's looking very smart right now
where the dollar is strengthening
against a whole basket of other fiat
currencies and of course the dollar and
the euro now when they reach parity
there's all kinds of jokes in there does
that mean the euro is now a stable coin
does that mean the peg is breaking maybe
you could even say does that mean that
the euro is a [ __ ] coin it's go on and
on and on but at the end of the day what
we're seeing is a dollar that's
strengthening and a euro that is
weakening on a relative basis and bam
you hit the crossover right at one
dollar
um sorry just really quick david from
the youtube comments said happy one year
anniversary best business show yeah that
is is that today yes it's been well that
is today oh yeah somebody a very nice
person i don't know if i'm supposed to
say who it is or not uh they
can i say it
oh all right uh well i don't know look i
respect people's privacy around here uh
jordy who is uh one of the people who uh
is a fantastic
video when it goes out to the jordan
you're matt that one of the two of them
cut it so i see you guys in the chat
every single day y'all streaming
jordy or matt one of the two cut it uh
jordy's mother shout out jordy's mom uh
sent a it's already called a cookie cake
cookie cake uh for one year we've all
been enjoying it i have not eaten it yet
uh maybe maybe i'll i'll load up
i'll dive in afterwards i don't want to
get uh what they call frosting on my
teeth
i come in here looking like i got green
teeth
but yeah who has great teeth who kevin
hart oh my god something that's kind of
hard
okay so i don't play that all the time
you know he's got great teeth kevin hart
so the dollar and the euro so why is
this important at all uh well because
the dollar strength in the euro is uh
weakening this is also happening other
currencies as well but this one in
particular in 20 years they have not
been at uh parity and so it's just
showing that uh the us at the end of the
day even though it has high inflation
even though it has all these issues uh
there are still enormous demand for us
dollars on a global basis and on a
relative basis uh you can see that
people prefer the dollar over some of
these other fiat currencies uh at least
in the short term that could change it
could reverse it could go sideways
whatever but right now we definitely uh
are seeing that the u.s dollar uh is
if you look at the euro people want
dollars more than euros because you're
seeing the euro weekend and the dollar
uh go ahead and strengthen
cool all right what's up with bill
ackman bill ackman
raised four billion dollars in the
biggest ever spac special purpose
acquisition company told investors he
would be returning the sum after failing
to find a suitable target company to
take public through the merger so stacks
are basically these like vehicles that
you invest money in and then bill ackman
or
such an investor goes out and picks a
target to acquire into the spec but he
looks like he didn't find one that's a
great description that's exactly what
happens anthony that that was a spec 101
but it's just so interesting to me
because like i guess spax people have to
trust the investor because you have no
idea what he's going to buy so there's a
couple of things uh that are worth
discussing here the first is your
description of a spec is exactly how it
works investors put the capital in they
have a uh an investor or a manager who's
supposed to go out with their team find
something but they have to come back to
the shareholders and get it approved
right so the shareholders basically it's
almost like you get kind of an option
and then there's a shareholder so
there's like a vote okay and either it
gets approved or doesn't now there's a
timeline and i forget the exact time
it's a year or three years whatever it
is uh where once they put the money in
you have a shot clock and if you don't
get a deal done you got to give the
money back yeah so what ends up
happening is these investors who in bill
ackman's case is four billion dollars
sitting there he's doing work him and
his team they're working they're working
they're looking at companies they're
trying to figure out which one should we
acquire all this stuff at the end of the
day they're not going to make a ton of
money because they're going to give the
cash back now kudos to them for giving
the cash back right they couldn't find
something great i don't know if they ran
up against the timeline or they just did
it at the kindness of their heart
probably timeline but they are giving
the money back uh the second thing that
i would say is there is a strong
argument
that actually uh depending on the
performance of the stock
it may have been better to have put your
cash in
not had a deal get done and then just
get your cash back given that the market
is down so significantly since the
beginning uh of the year that's crazy
well it it depends on uh kind of all of
you know what else would you have uh
invested in all that but like in some
ways uh this would ended up being a
great investment because you just didn't
have exposure uh to let's say a business
that was acquired by us
back and then went down 70 percent that
just means you lost 70 of your money
right so there there's some uh maybe
some sunshine
or some optimism in uh this story uh but
still obviously people invested because
they wanted to go find a company they uh
bill ackman and his team uh uh
definitely wanted to go find a company
uh and so they weren't able to do that
that's okay yeah so typically a spec you
have to buy the company
uh between 18 and 24 months and then uh
it says that he had initially um he had
initially planned for the spec to take a
stake in universal music group last year
when these investment vehicles were all
the rage but ended up not yeah i think
there was some issues uh in terms of um
i came over from regulation there was
something that uh happened uh but he was
definitely going after the universal was
was one of the targets do you want to
invest in mice spec
and then i will go acquire something on
amazon prime day
and you won't know what it is
no
what's going on
all right
pelton has a great product by the way
peloton will stop making its own bikes
not a great product uh its own bikes and
treadmills a drastic change for the
struggling company aimed at cutting
costs and ensuring its ability to remain
afloat apologize really struggling this
is the new ceo uh part of their plan uh
yes and uh my guess is that by doing
this they believe they can get more
efficiency and lower cost bikes uh out
to the market at the end of the day
peloton doesn't wanna be a hardware
manufacturer you don't get the highest
multiple uh you don't uh get all the
benefits of claiming your technology
company like there's a bunch of
challenges when you have the hardware
component and so we've seen a ton of
businesses uh who have a hardware
component trying to over time go and
transition into more of a software-based
business
peloton one of their big revenue sources
or at least what they believe is going
to be
a huge driver of future growth is they
have a digital subscription if i
remember correctly i don't know what the
numbers look like on that digital
subscription business but that's been a
huge focus of theirs is just get that
subscription revenue uh going now a huge
part of driving subscription revenue was
you had to sell the bikes you said the
treadmills uh but they were trying to
also basically say just get the peloton
app you don't even need our hardware and
we can do classes they have like yoga
and bars yes weightlifting so at the end
of the day uh this is less like a shock
to the market i think this is just a
continuation of all these hardware
companies trying to become
as software based as possible
also though
when you get a new ceo that comes in
it's easier to kind of rip the band-aid
off right because you can basically just
step into a business and say to yourself
all right
where are we struggling where are we not
fresh eyes rip the band-aid off make the
changes now that usually includes
layoffs that includes hiring initiatives
that includes things like hey we're
gonna get rid of the hardware and just
outsource it now all these things the
market is much more accepting of on day
one
or early on in a new ceo's role because
they expect things to change when a new
ceo comes in well but i just i i think
that it's smart
to bring everything kind of in-house and
especially if that cuts costs
but i'm guessing if they're going to
make their own hardware it's going to
increase like wait times
uh if they make their own yeah yeah well
that's been one of the big problems i
think is when uh covet happened uh
people were forced at home so what do
you do if you're forced at home you
still want to work out then naturally
you either you live in an apartment
building with a gym but a lot of those
even got shut down uh you can you know
sneak outside and go for a run you can
do push-ups like you know whatever
there's a gentleman who ran a marathon
on his little balcony uh you know
there's all that type of stuff that we
saw people doing but at the end of the
day what people really want is they
wanna you have a piece of uh
a machine right and that could be a
rowing machine that could be a bicycle
that could be uh a treadmill whatever
and so peloton was a huge winner from
that because people saw sales exploding
upwards uh they saw the hardware and the
software getting uh put together
vertical integration they were bragging
about and they got it out in the market
what people realized over time though is
like how big of a audience is there for
this and if you look at the hardware
sales that part of the business is way
less exciting than the digital
subscription so now if they can just do
digital subscriptions then we're off to
the races
what do you see my shirt on backward i
just realized what is this okay
[Laughter]
guys today is
not monday it's tuesday it's just all
over the place um
so okay facebook
i love my wife facebook may be infamous
in helping usher in like this era of
like fake news and whatever but
now meta
facebook facebook's glow up company um
is trying to
combat fake news by creating this like
tool called sphere
it's very interesting it's
i watched a video on it it's really cool
it's automatically scanning entries to
identify when like things are
strongly or weakly supported its first
user is wikipedia so basically it'll
tell you if a claim is strongly
supported by research on the internet or
weakly supported and it's just gonna you
know help with accuracy purposes so
i have two reactions the first is uh the
whole idea of
truth
is highly debatable around a lot of
different topics so you can sit there
and you can say to somebody uh did x
happen
and you take two people who both
experience the same data uh synthesized
it and they come to two different
conclusions okay but this is not that
well hold on a second
uh plane and i recently were talking
about there's a study um it's an
academic study where a professor in the
beginning of uh his course i think it's
like on the first day he's standing up
in front of hundreds of students and he
has a
actor or former student whatever ta
run in the room and rob him
and then run out of the room and then he
says everyone stop right now and write
down what just happened describe the
perpetrator
and so everyone writes it down and what
you get is some people are like oh that
was a person was five seven another
person that person was six two uh that
person was uh white that person was
hispanic like they all write down
different um uh kind of descriptions of
the events and of the person and the
study is to show that even with
eyewitness accounts there can be variety
in people who all saw the same thing but
their record recollection of it could be
off
and so
that to me is
one of the inherent problems with these
things you talk about eyewitness
accounts i'm talking like facts
but i forget if the eyewitnesses can't
all agree on the facts of what happened
in front of them how does a piece of ai
do it all the time now there are some
things for sure like what's the date
that should be pretty easy for you not
just that like it it scours through
studies that maybe people haven't read
like encyclopedias like things like that
where yes like i forget who said it
there's a great quote it's like there's
three sides to every story yours mine
and the truth
um but i i actually really like this
because if you use wikipedia or anything
like that and you want to check the
sources you can go down to the footnotes
section but this
does it for you and that it scours the
whole internet and then it tells you
like hey it's widely supported or not
that widely supported i think that's
helpful it's not saying this is the only
i think that these are very important i
think we'll see many more companies or
projects come out and try to build
similar types of things uh the big
question though is can they get it right
because it's a very hard technical
problem uh and it's not just technical
in nature it's also uh the elements of
if people don't agree on eyewitness
accounts
no but exactly if there was an ai in
that room forget all the witness
eyewitness accounts the ai is like this
is exactly what happened he was five
seven he was whatever
yes that is all algorithms have you ever
seen uh just just google real quick for
a second uh just google the um story
about uh there was an algorithm that i
think was doing facial recognition and
people said that it was discriminating
i'm sure if i remember correctly yeah
and the whole idea was uh
it wasn't because somebody sat down and
was like let's write an algorithm that
discriminates it was learning it's
machine learning and so it was learning
over time how to do all this stuff and
people basically came back and said hey
we have work to do not that we should
all stop using this technology but
there's obviously problems we should go
well because the ai is built by a human
who is also inherently can i call out
one thing though that's changed in the
last uh 15 years or so when i was in
high school you weren't allowed to uh
cite wikipedia true you were not like
that was looked down on now media has
grown so much yeah now it's like oh of
course wikipedia may be the best source
but when i was in
middle school high school like that was
not a cool source to use see for me when
i was in high school they said you can
use wikipedia as long as as long as you
use the footnote section and go to the
original source if the original source
is bad don't use it obviously guys we
were still covering the keyboard trying
to do typing class so uh it makes sense
that by the time you uh you you got
there they were like wikipedia no
problem i'm pretty sure also one of the
big issues with wikipedia when was uh
wikipedia founded uh one of the big
problems was that it was really easy to
uh to change stuff yeah
at the time
um wow so yeah in january of 20 uh 2001
it began as a side project uh to allow
collaboration articles prior to entering
the peer review process uh and then
eventually it launched uh 11 january
2001 um or that's when the name was
suggested wikipedia and so like to be
new pedia like literally wikipedia was
created while i was in middle school
like i think in uh september of 2001 uh
with that's 911 i was in eighth grade
i was still in like fifth yeah wow
younger so by the time i got to high
school the next year they were like what
is this thing this thing isn't even a
year old yet
yeah all right what's going on with
james webb i can't wait to talk about
this all right the james webb telescope
has produced the deepest and sharpest
infrared image of the distant universe
to date so each of these little dots
that you see on the screen right now are
galaxies so just like the milky way
every single one of those is a separate
one so that means that there's like
planets like other things that circle
around like or that are part of this
galaxy
what do you think about this
what did i tell you last night that i
think about it yeah that's what i think
about it so i think it's really cool i
think it's absolutely amazing
but
my biggest problem with this is that we
have the sharpest imagery of things in
the past of galaxies far far away yet
yet we can't get a non-blurry picture
of a baby in the womb
[Laughter]
literally they make the babies look like
alien cats
and they are basically there's like one
tiny barrier between you and the
how is that possible that that's what
you thought of when you saw the james
webb telescope one of the greatest
technology inventions in the last 20
years let's invent something else first
and then we can talk james webb
well the the telescope uh i found it
interesting they started building it in
1996 and it was supposed to go live in
2006 so about a decade or so um and it
was gonna cost 500 million dollars in
2005 the year before was supposed to
launch uh they completely redesigned the
whole thing kicked it out again it was
finally finished in 2016.
in 2016 they then from 2016 to december
of 2021 they tested it extensive testing
is what i was reading about and then
they launched it december of 2021 and we
just got the first photos now in july uh
guess the cost of it was supposed to be
500 million how much do you think they
spent total to get this thing launched
that was a great guess like 9.7 9.8
billion
um and uh uh when you think about just
it took two and a half times longer took
20 times the money to get it launched
but we still get that great photo uh
that's pretty cool but my general take
is although yes i agree we should get
better pictures of wombs
oh babies or babies
is uh this makes humans feel so damn
insignificant
right i know
like that that is a picture
of
light from billions of years ago
billions
not
one year not ten years not a hundred not
a thousand not a hundred thousand not a
million years oh gosh you're all gonna
be gone one day billions of years ago oh
god oh no oh god
yeah people get like somebody said uh
somebody said it in the comments they
said it is because the baby does not
emit light
that's why we can't get
it's very astute
analysis the audience is smart last
thing i'll say you know what else that
photo proves
what there's definitely aliens out there
100
how does that prove anything are you
kidding me look at that you're telling
me
that of billions and billions and
billions and billions of years
all those different galaxies and planets
and stars all that stuff there ain't
nothing else
talking [ __ ] like us believe that we're
aliens to the aliens you know oh damn
wow are you high right now
we're aliens to the aliens that's why
y'all tune in every single day
all right thank you so much for uh for
coming on fellow ufo yeah
happy first birthday to the best
business show there we go uh by the way
just so we're clear ufos are not aliens
it's a it's a nuance but it is an
important one the ufos are unidentified
flying that's exactly what i wanted to
call you in the ufo all right